Let's get right into audience questions
for this week. First one is interesting,
relates to a thing, to a few different things
we've talked about over the last few years. And
the question is, what is the most likely
future of socialism in the United States?
If you watched the recent State of the Union
addresses from Donald Trump, you would know
that this powerful, defiant declaration that
the U.S. will never be a socialist country
is both an impossible prediction to make, because
the truth is, we're terrible at predicting things
even five years out. Who knows what the U.S.
could look like 20, 30, 50, 100 years out.
But it's also particularly its meaninglessly
propagandistic in the sense that there's no
threat that the U.S. is about to become socialist,
despite Donald Trump continuing to campaign on
Biden's been taken over by the Socialists. The
people Trump claims are controlling Biden aren't,
by and large, actual socialists. And certainly
there's nothing socialistic about Joe Biden's
policy. So the fear mongering about the U.S.
becoming socialist is very, very silly, but it
does seem to at least activate some of the people
on the right. But I think those people are mostly
supporting Donald Trump anyway. I think it's
essentially a wash. So then we get to a Trump free
discussion of the possible future of socialism
in the United States, as I have said before.
I have seen no evidence that if the U.S. is to
become a socialist country and again, this is not
about my views. I'm not a socialist. I'm a social
Democrat, which is a form of highly regulated
capitalism. If the country is to become socialist,
I believe that you would need to see first of all,
actual socialists have some amount of power in the
United States. Now, this could be socialist groups
or socialist politicians. Right now I don't see
either. And I believe it would be incremental. It
would go through social democracy. Acceleration
ism is the idea when applied to socialism,
capitalism, that by accelerating capitalism,
which some socialists believe will fail.
Some Marxist, some communists believe will fail.
You accelerate the eventual revolution that will
turn the country socialistic. Much has been said
theoretically about that and written theoretically
about that. I believe that in practice at this
point in time, again, in five years, maybe I'd
have a different view because things dramatically
change right now. I don't see how, for example,
giving Trump another four years and cutting
regulations and giving more market power.
I don't think that if that causes a breakdown, it
results in the United States becoming socialist.
If and so this is why I've said time and again to
actual socialists, of which there are relatively
few in the United States. Many of the people
who even think they are socialists aren't really
socialists. Up for now, you should just be joining
the fight for social democracy because the path
to let me put it a different way. The best proof
that the United States should go in that direction
would be to go in that direction. And that would
mean looking at health care more like northern
European countries. Look at it, looking at
taxation more the way northern European countries
look at it, look at education, social welfare
programs, etc.. In the last decade, we have seen
socialists go from really more of an insult and
not something many people would use to describe
themselves to kind of like a pretty ho hum.
You know, it's just a word. It's almost become
like progressive, although it means very different
things where Trump says all his opponents are
socialists. Very few people really believe
it. Young people are more okay with the term
than we've seen people be in a very long time. So
I think that and it's not for me to give advice
to the actual socialists not being one, but if you
are an actual socialist, you should capitalize on
the most positive or least negative view of
socialism that there has been in the U.S. in
a long time by pushing the country in any
ways that are possible in that direction.
The best argument you can make for socialism being
great would be for social democracy to work really
well. And if we ever got to that point, then I
and the Socialists would be on different sides.
But but right now, even though many of the
socialists believe they're on a different side
than me, the next step, whether you want social
democracy, is the end point or you want socialism,
as the endpoint would be to move in that direction
when it comes to all of the major areas of policy
in the United States. It's certainly not going to
happen with another four years of Donald Trump.